CEO fires unpaid intern today has anyone
watched that
is it good is it funny
that didn't sound convincing
it's funny depending on who you are we
watch this and Cody's agreeing with
everyone what'd you say yeah yeah I'm
like what was the revenue like
Cody puts a CEO pants on
I'm the businessman that's a good he
does in his house he puts on black
slacks he's like I'm boss baby I'm the
boss baby
that's why I search business pants all
day yeah yeah still trying to find a
good pair yeah I'm the boss baby yeah
seriously
you knew we were gonna talk today have
you lost your [__] mind yeah I knew
that was gonna talk today no no
no no
hey how's your work
it don't work like that
somebody reaches out to you you the
protocol the process improves normal
etiquette bus process and Protocol no
more etiquette
is that you say something you don't just
say nothing
that's not how this works look honestly
if you were anybody else I'd say [__]
you get the [__] out of my company
that's what I did to my nephew and
that's my [__] nephew that's my blood
and I HR just
oh boy hey here we go oh boy just hell
of violations I love him you understand
what I'm saying
you don't just not say anything that
[__] is rude as [__] do you understand
that
I'm sorry that you feel that way I just
knew that we're gonna get together today
I feel that way
if this is what you want to do we're
done now with this [__] you got going on
is disrespectful
I have to give credit to the CEO the way
he uses the word [__] is hitting hard
it's hitting it's really it's hitting
hard yeah definitely if you lost I'd be
filming this too [__] mine yeah
bro yeah bro
honestly the way you're hitting that
[__]
bro are you the CEO or is this like uh
is this an audition
you are murdering this [__] hold on keep
keep it going man keep that going I'm
sending this around town this is crazy
what you're doing right here
I love when people
um
uh like when you see arguments online
and people will call out to someone that
is like a family like that or someone
that's close to them it's like I did
this to my best friend I kicked him in
the balls yeah and that's my best friend
it's like oh my God that's not telling
on yourself exactly don't say [__] like
that I told my own blood to go [__]
himself it's like that's not cool yeah
so what are you gonna do to me yeah so
what are you gonna do to me I kicked my
nephew in his ass yeah whole I put my
toe in his ass hole and that's my nephew
as a CEO of this company I have the mind
to stick my whole knee in your ass
you ever seen perverse family
that's what I did to my nephew yeah they
did me an ass in in perverse man yeah
they did
what are you gonna do to me are we oh
nothing I like you I hate my family yeah
oh okay yeah no sorry you're cool
I'm so pissed off about my nephews yeah
that's why I'm in such a bad sorry I'm
triggered man you did something that
reminded me of my nephew and it reminded
me the time when I kicked him in his
[__] nuts sorry let me just come back
down here your nephew too that's my
blood and I love him but I had to kick
him in the ball you know how that goes
right you know you have to kick your own
blood in the balls
you gotta Jam your foot and your
nephew's nuts you know how that goes
it's weird because they're small because
he's young you know he's only 15. they
haven't even fully come out yet yeah I
kicked him in the balls one of them
wasn't there my toe went up in his body
my toe was looking for the nut in his
stomach and that's my nephew you know
anyway sorry man you're cool yeah you're
cool so uh let's talk about that race
no
no no boring this is kind of
uncomfortable and and it drags it gets
stronger it's just going for 11 minutes
so after the video ends someone talks
about it and there's context of how this
happened
and it's nine minutes of context
oh this seems like a bad story wait who
is this like a random guy that analyzes
this
yeah I think the who would watch a video
like this and talk about it for 10
minutes yeah yeah
nine minutes of context are you sure
hard cut so when he applied
oh right yes so it turns out he was his
nephew yeah which is that's the craziest
part yeah his own blood yeah so he's a
he's a but then the guy in the video it
turns out is the other nephew of the
nephew so they're step nephews is this
this is why everyone's making that's why
CEOs are all making people come back to
the office yeah you know yeah just so
they can't film Zoom calls yeah they
can't get caught yeah with their
employees anymore yeah yeah CEO gets
caught asking for employees underwear um
we're coming back into the office
we need to be at our desks
ready to go
that'd be a good sketch a CEO
barking about how we need to go back in
office and we need to be professional we
need to run this company correctly
thank you and he stands up and turns
around he's got assless underwear
sitting at his computer so stupid
I laughed it was good
some stupid ass dumbass [__] joke
I'm such a [__] idiot I'm the type of
[__] guy to take two and a half hours
to get to the [__] no that's me and
that's not that bad
you know honestly I have to thank you
for that
because I was feeling kind of mid and
then when I saw that text I want to
thank
yeah no it's
both of us now
that's just rude like that just
you want to make you feel better
honestly you want coffee I do actually
can we get mute this can I can I smack
that oh you got it already
I was gonna I was gonna hijack his order
no but if if I have to wait what do you
mean like I'm gonna order it now and
then wait for it we get it on the break
no but they have coffee right now right
you have one in hand right now
I need instant relief thank you hey man
I just want to say
as owners of an organization
we cannot use phrases like I need
instant relief
we can never talk like that
okay if you're on a zoom call yeah
just generally you can't
we can't come into this building and go
I need some instant relief
who's got instant relief for me people's
hands are gonna start trembling on their
computers like uh
[Music]
that's good calm down that's good holy
[__] you hate the [__] right there bro
bro eat the [__]
bro was tasting a different type of
coffee bean
man you really like you mouth that
coffee you like that yeah it's really
good too it's strong we all heard that
right we all heard that that
you moaned a little because I was
thinking about it
like
no I was thinking about it like on the
drive here you think about her yeah like
an hour into it that's usually when I
would hit my lips you know so I'm
conditioned
it's an hour drive and then it's like
again instant relief it's my lips yeah
yeah
but then another hour and a half goes by
yeah and I still haven't had any instant
relief yeah
exactly
do you do you find this do you now
never
yeah I agree Asians like what wait what